- Ça commence avec p...
madame Girard?
- Diane et Carole jouent
au bonhomme pendu avec
leur nouvel ami, un des deux
robots qui a élu domicile
au Centre d'hébergement
Armand-Lavergne et qui aide
à mettre un peu de piquant
dans la vie des résidents.
- Ça fait passer le temps plus
vite que si t'es tout seul dans
un appartement puis qu'il n'y a
pas d'activités.
Ça travaille mon esprit.
Il a besoin de nourriture,
c'est vrai pareil.
- Le robot peut faire
la lecture avec des résidents,
on a des quiz, on peut comme
animer des quiz, il peut animer
tout seul des quiz avec
des résidents, demander
des questions.
- Parce qu'en effet, il parle.
- Que puis-je faire pour vous?
- Bonjour Cuti, c'est quoi
la météo aujourd'hui?
- Il fait actuellement
16 degrés avec un temps nuageux.
- Et il marche aussi.
Il s'en va rejoindre
son collègue dans la salle
commune, qui se prépare
à diffuser un récital en direct.
- Je vous invite à chanter avec
moi si vous en avez envie,
donc c'est "La vie en rose".
- Un autre moment de détente
et de divertissement.
♪ Je vois la vie en rose ♪
- La soliste qui offre
une prestation peut contrôler
le robot à distance,
et l'approcher des résidents
pour interagir.
- Qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
que je vous chante?
- Dans le cadre du projet-
pilote, des robots côtoient
les résidents dans trois CHSLD
montréalais depuis juin.
- Ça amène toute
la personnalisation de l'offre
services-loisirs, qu'on puisse
avoir une variété beaucoup
plus grande qui va toucher
vraiment individuellement
les résidents.
- En premier, j'ai trouvé ça
intimidant, puis à près ça, d'un
coup que tu connais, ça va bien.
- On vient qu'on s'habitue,
c'est comme si on parlait
au téléphone puis que vous
parlez avec une autre personne
qui vous répond.
- Le projet-pilote se terminera
vers la fin de l'été.
Si l'expérience est concluante,
d'autres robots pourraient
déménager dans les CHSLD.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio